-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for being here.
Well, guys,
here's some good news --
after being closed last year
because of the pandemic,
it was just announced
that Times Square
will be open on New Year's Eve
for the fully vaccinated.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yep, only in New York City
could thousands of people
peeing and puking
in Times Square
be seen
as "getting back to normal,"
you know what I'm saying?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah!
We're back to --
[ Laughter ]
-[ Retches ]
-That's right, everyone there
must be fully vaccinated.
Officials say the only thing
you should go home with is
hypothermia.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, this is
a pretty crazy story --
apparently,
Russia just fired a missile
that blew up one
of their old satellites
and it created thousands
of pieces of debris in space.
[ Audience oohs ]
Vladimir Putin was like --
[ As Putin ]
Sorry, it was gender reveal
[ Laughter and applause ]
gone way too far.
Hey --
[ Laughter ]
Follow me on TikTok.
I have more videos like that.
I just goof off, have fun,
stuff like that.
[ Laughter ]
Some news
from the White House --
last night,
President Biden finally had
his virtual summit
with Chinese President Xi.
It lasted more
than three hours.
Yeah, for three hours,
they debated a bunch of issues
without reaching any kind
of agreement.
In other words, they celebrated
Thanksgiving earlier.
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right.
Just let's agree to disagree.
Today, President Biden visited
a structurally deficient bridge
in New Hampshire, to sell
his infrastructure plan...
[ Laughter ]
...and he had to do
a bit of walking,
a bit of walking to get
to the podium. Watch this.
-The president
of the United States,
Joseph R. Biden Jr.
[ Laughter ]
Dude, look at this.
Dude, look.
[ Laughter ]
Dude, they're --
What the...?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Holy...
-Thank you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We actually played that
at double speed.
[ Laughter ]
Then, Biden was like, "Oh,
hang on, I forgot my speech."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You want to start the Amer--
[ Laughter ]
Ladies and gentleman,
the president --
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "You got to be
kidding me, man."
By the time he got to the mic,
half the bridge
had already been demolished.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
Meanwhile,
I saw that House Democrats
are trying to pass a nearly
$2 trillion spending package.
But some people are worried
that they won't be able
to unite in time
to pass it before the holidays.
A few Democrats have even
released statements
about the whole thing.
Check this out.
Congressman David Price said...
[ Laughter ]
Next up,
Congressman Josh Harder said...
[ Laughter ]
Congresswoman Susan Wild said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
There's more.
-More?
There's more people.
[ Laughter ]
Congresswoman Karen Bass said...
And Congressman
Jared Huffman said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And Congresswoman
Lisa Blunt Rochester --
[ Laughter ]
-Lisa Blunt Rochester?
Okay.
-Lisa Blunt Rochester,
she was like...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There's more people.
-Really?
-Yeah, Congressman Al Green
said...
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, Congressman
Charles Albert "Dutch"
Ruppersberger III said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Well, get this -- yesterday,
the Environmental Protection
Agency announced
the country's first national
recycling strategy, yeah.
Then, today, they announced
the country's first
national recycling strategy.
[ Scattered laughter
and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] What?
[ Laughter ]
Today, they announced
the country's first
national recycling strategy.
Yep, the strategy's
just one sentence --
"Stop forgetting that you have
tote bags in your trunk."
That's it.
[ Laughter ]
Ah, in my -- yeah.
It counts, right?
"No, it doesn't."
Finally, General Motors just
announced that the chip shortage
has gotten so bad,
some of its new cars
won't have heated seats.
[ Audience oohs ]
At the same time, Hyundai
is reminding people that,
if their seats are warm,
it's because the engine is
on fire.
[ Laughter and applause ]